digamos que el precio de liquidación
para la entrega de mil kilogramos de
manzanas que será el 20 de octubre donde
vamos a suponer que será dentro de un
año serán 200 pesos y también vamos a
suponer que el precio actual del mercado
para 1000 kilogramos de manzanas también
es de 200 pesos así que dicho precio de
liquidación es el mismo que el precio
del mercado y también asumiremos o vamos
a suponer como en el último ejemplo que
estas manzanas nunca se echarán a perder
que son simplemente cosas que nunca se
pudren ni mucho menos que están bien
durante todo el año como lo están
ahorita ahora también vamos a suponer
que más allá de todos estos supuestos
del último vídeo que también vamos a
poder pedir prestado y vender las
manzanas en el mercado que podemos de
hecho contar con dichas manzanas y pedir
las prestadas podemos ir con alguien que
tenga mil kilogramos de manzanas y
decirle que nos las preste puesto que
las van a necesitar hasta el próximo año
y de los intereses que nos generen de
estos cinco por ciento de intereses que
nos generen las manzanas al vender
le vamos a dar dueño 1% de estos
intereses y la persona diría oh claro
porque no de esa forma de hecho yo
obtengo un poco de dinero de mis
manzanas a las cuales no les tengo
intenciones de usar en un año y luego
como el prestador y el vendedor obtendré
el 4% neto voy a obtener el 4% de las
manzanas así que dando esta realidad que
podría hacer una vez más esta ganancia
libre de riesgo entonces lo voy a anotar
por acá arriba bien pues como puedes
imaginar te podemos pedir prestadas
manzanas y venderlas por años entonces
al pedir prestados mil kilogramos de
manzanas y venderlos voy a obtener 200
pesos ahora encima de esto recuerda que
debemos regresar las manzanas pues
fueron prestadas así que podemos hacer
un contrato para estar de acuerdo
estaríamos de acuerdo de ser
estaremos de acuerdo decir el comprador
de ser el comprador
el contrato futuro del contrato futuro y
ahora yendo a lo largo de este año yo no
a lo largo de este año vamos a comprar
las manzanas en 200 pesos entonces
nosotros al ser el comprador de este
contrato obtuvimos 200 pesos de manzana
de ganancias perdón ahora hay que
comprar unas nuevas manzanas para
regresarse las al que nos las prestó y
aparte darle el 1% de los intereses que
me hayan generado a lo largo de este año
entonces de los 200 pesos que gane de
vender las manzanas obtuve el 5 por
ciento de estas pero le tuve que dar el
1 por ciento de la persona que me lo
prestó por lo que estoy obteniendo el 4%
y el 4% de 200 pesos son 8 pesos por lo
que ahora tengo 208 pesos eran 210 pero
le dimos 2 pesos a la persona que nos
prestó las manzanas ahora estos 200
pesos de aquí son para comprar las
manzanas y defender mi posición en el
contrato que estoy diciendo que haré en
un futuro entonces 200 pesos
la compra de las manzanas y sí que puedo
hacer esto independientemente del precio
que hay ahorita en el mercado pues es el
precio de entrega que parte de mi
contrato futuro y entonces tenemos 8
pesos netos estos 200 pesos fueron para
regresar las manzanas y a mí me quedaron
8 pesos netos de los 1000 kilogramos de
manzanas que estuvimos teniendo para
generar los intereses que nos dejaron 8
pesos netos los cuales gané libres de
riesgo así que si lo piensas una vez más
esta es una especie de límite inferior
sobre lo que actualmente es el precio de
liquidación del contrato y no debería de
estar haciendo esto para ganar lo libre
de riesgo pues si estuviera válido la
gente lo haría lo cual alteraría la
oferta y la demanda de la economía